the doctor strange story is a great cast  of characters chief among them is Carla  mortel well it certainly is the intro to  Doctor Strange entering this this  universe moto is very close with the  ancient one played by Tilda Swinton she  deals in magic in real proper inner  magic together both the ancient one moto  they sort of begin his training there  are other ways to save lives so much you  don't know  we're excited about villains in this  film we call them the zealots these are  people who become seduced by what they  find on the other side Casillas is part  of this temple if the majority is  looking for the truth here he's looking  over there for the truth he is  interested in spilling the barriers  between these dimensions  the reality you know is one of many this  doesn't make any sense not everything